so I just finished competing in the
Olympics and last week going on a date
with Liz hi I'm Liz I'm here working the
Olympics I've made it my mission to go
on a date with an Olympian so I've been
traveling since a date and we haven't
been able to cross paths since then so
she just actually just texted me and
she's heading to the airport
I'm literally nowhere near the airport
like an hour away I could just let her
leave so I wanted to figure out a way to
meet up with her before I should leave
so I could say goodbye I just got her
some flowers and a little bit of
chocolate and I think I'm gonna surprise
her at the airport so right now I'm
texting Liz and trying to figure out the
more details about a fly out when she
heads off without giving her too much
information saying that I'm coming and
trying to surprise it so just got out of
the taxi just got to the Seoul station
and gonna try to run and find the
correct train to make it on time before
she leaves so my head I had planned out
that it's indeed some epic run
last-minute catch her give her a goodbye
hug maybe a goodbye kiss before she
leaves and have it play out like a fairy
tale or one of those really cool movies
that our chick flicks traffic was
horrible hopefully I don't miss it so I
just bought a train ticket no idea if
it's the right one
I'm just hoping it is and I'm hoping to
catch up with her before she goes
through security
so normally I never do this kind of
stuff but just because I think it's
entertaining for both us me and Liz
train just arrived I'm super excited
kind of nervous in this trailer it's
been sweet check this up now I'm on the
train and I just get a message from Liz
that she just went through security all
this effort and everything I'm put
forward to try to catch up and say
goodbye so I'm not even sure if I'm
gonna be able to see her before she goes
to the states now this complain epic
fail so I just got to the airport and I
just texted it than I'm here is where
are you going apparently Robbie's
outside waiting to say bye so I guess I
have to go so I'm going to see if I can
meet him but I honestly have no idea oh
my god I'm with Shanae now and she is
walking with me to try and help me get
to the other side of security and this
is crazy
[Music]
we've gone to her supervisor and now
we're going to someone else I am sitting
in this chair and they want me to
explain my reason
to an immigration officer
so now I'm waiting here the check-in
gate for Liz to come out we'll see if
she makes it because it's now definitely
gonna be close to her fight oh my god so
I'm definitely not sure which side
coming out up so I just keep looking
both ways and Security's like watching
me because I'm watching everyone and
everything so closely so I hopefully
don't get kicked out before meeting up
with Liz it's been an hour and 20
minutes so I'm sorry to get anxious
because I'm supposed to meet with my dad
soon for dinner like him too far too
close to not say goodbye
[Music]
my god I just got back through security
somehow and I'm now trying to find
Robbie I look like a ICG
[Music]
guess who just showed up yes I'm super
bummed because I've been waiting all
this time it just makes it so much
better when she comes around the corner
all right let's just made it and now
we're gonna give her the best gift ever
[Music]
liz is freaking out right now
[Music]
oh yeah the taxi went the wrong way got
off on terminal 1 and then found out
you're in terminal 2 so yeah I was kind
of a struggle but made it so she just
told me she cancelled her flight to be
able to leave but there should be able
to check her back in so we'll see if it
works cause this says account this is
not official we have to go to Mexico
City I'm in LA so let's meet in like
Tijuana on the board spin one go the
beach or see something crazy just barely
made it back on my plane
I don't know if it went as well as I
wanted because I kind of wanted to get a
kiss in it before she flew off but at
the same time I'm super pumped that I
was able to see her and it makes me even
more excited to go on date number two